so we have nine students who recently
graduated from a small school that has a
class size of nine
and they want to figure out what is the
central tendency for salaries one year
after graduation and they also want to
have a sense of the spread around that
central tendency one year after
graduation so they all agree to put in
their salaries into a computer and so
these are their salaries that measured
in thousands so one makes thirty five
thousand fifty thousand fifty thousand
fifty thousand fifty six thousand to
make sixty thousand one make seventy
five thousand and one makes 250 000 so
she's doing very well for herself
and the computer it spits out a bunch of
parameters based on this data here
so it spits out two typical measures of
central tendency the mean is roughly
76.2 the computer would calculate it by
adding up all of these numbers these
nine numbers and then dividing by nine
and the median is 56 and median is quite
easy to calculate you just order the
numbers and you take the middle number
here which is 56.
now what i want you to do is pause this
video and think about
for this data set for this population of
salaries
which measure which measure of central
tendency is a better measure
all right so let's think about this a
little bit i'm going to plot it
on a line here i'm going to plot my data
so we get a better sense so we just
don't see them so we just don't see
things as
numbers but we see where those numbers
sit relative to each other so let's say
this is zero
let's say this is let's see one
two
three
four
five so this would be 250
this is 50 100
100 200
200 and let's see let's say if this is
50 then
this would be roughly
40 right here and i just want to get
rough so this would be about 60
70 80 90. close enough i could draw this
a little bit neater but
60 70 80 90.
actually let me just clean this up a
little bit more too this one right over
here would be a little bit closer
so this one
let me just put it right around
here so that's 40 and then this would be
20 10. okay that's pretty good so let's
plot this data so one student makes 35
000 so that is right
over there
to make 50. or 3 make 50 000. so 1
[Music]
and 3. i'll put it like that one makes
56 000 which would put them
right over
here
one makes sixty thousand actually two
makes sixty thousand so it's like that
one makes seventy five thousand so
that's sixty seventy seventy five
thousand this one's going to be right
around there
and then one makes two hundred and fifty
000.
so one's salary is all the way around
there
and then when we calculate the mean as
76.2 as our measure of central tendency
76.2
is right over there
so is this a good measure of central
tendency
well to me it doesn't feel that good
because our measure of central tendency
is higher than all of the data points
except for one and the reason is is that
you have this one that that that our our
data is skewed significantly by this
data point at 250 000 it is so far from
the rest of the distribution from the
rest of the data that it has skewed the
mean and this is something that you see
in general if you have data that is
skewed and especially things like salary
data where someone might make most
people are making 50 60 70 000 but
someone might make 2 million and so that
will skew the average or skew the mean i
should say when you add them all up and
divide by the number of data points you
have
in this case especially when you have
data points that would skew the mean
median is much more robust the median at
56 sits right over here which seems to
be much more indicative for central
tendency and think about it even if you
made this instead of 250 000 if you made
this 250 000 000 which would be 250
million dollars which is a ginormous
amount of money to make it wouldn't it
would skew the mean incredibly but it
actually would not even change the
median because the median it doesn't
matter how high this number gets this
could be a trillion dollars this could
be a quadrillion dollars the median is
going to stay the same so the median is
much more robust if you have a skewed
data set mean makes a little bit more
sense if you have a symmetric data set
or if you have things that are you know
where things are roughly above and below
the mean or things aren't skewed
incredibly in one direction especially
by a handful of data points like we have
right over here
so in this example the median is a much
better measure of central tendency and
so what about spread
well you might immediately say well sal
you already told us that that the mean
is not so good and the standard
deviation is based on the mean you take
each of these data points find their
distance from the mean square that
number add up those squared distances
divide by the number of data points if
we're taking the population standard
deviation and then you and then you you
take the square root of the whole thing
and so since this is based on the mean
which isn't a good measure of central
tendency in this situation and this
this is also going to skew that standard
deviation this is going to be this is a
lot larger than if you look at the the
actual
you want an indication of the spread yes
you have this one data point that's way
far away from either the mean or the
median depending on how you want to
think about it but most of the data
points seem much closer and so for that
situation
not only are we using the median but the
interquartile range is once again more
robust how do we calculate the
interquartile range well you take the
median and then you take the bottom
group of numbers and calculate the
median of those so that's 50 right over
here and then you take the top group of
numbers the upper group of numbers and
the median there 60 and 75 is
67.5 if this looks unfamiliar we have
many videos on interquartile range and
calculating standard deviation and
median and mean this is just a little
bit of review and then the difference
between these two is 17.5
and notice this distance between these
two this 17.5
this isn't going to change even if this
is 250 billion dollars so once again it
is both of these measures are more
robust when you have a skewed data set
so the big takeaway here is mean
standard deviation they're not bad if
you have a roughly symmetric data set if
you don't have any significant outliers
things that really skew the data set
mean and standard deviation can be quite
solid but if you're looking at something
that could get really skewed by a
handful of data points median might be a
median and interquartile range median
for central tendency interquartile range
for spread around that central tendency
and that's why you'll see when people
talk about salaries they'll often talk
about median because you could have some
skewed salaries especially on the upside
we talk about things like home prices
you'll see median often
measured more typically than mean
because home prices in a neighborhood a
lot of or in a city a lot of the houses
might be in the 200
300 000 range but maybe there's one
ginormous mansion that is a hundred
million dollars and if you calculated
mean that would skew and give a false
impression of the average or the central
tendency of prices in that city